welcome to this video I'm playing Jess
long from where it's tricky yeah the
some Latin American country no it's
Thailand I guess this one right before
yeah well ok it's a French French
steinitz classical French here there's a
big party over the ways a 6b five is one
line they don't don't really know it in
much detail this is I think the the
traditional way to play the Sun this
opening maybe not the most promising
nowadays i think they play a play
differently this is good like to get an
ID to deform yeah don't think there's a
technical glitch
hmm
ninety-four again
what's a queen f2 is a month I might
play in my play Bishop to b5 so like to
control b5 here first interesting I am
expected something else okay more like
94 was what I expected but we all know
is playing that okay
I wonder if I really want to take
immediately no not yet
surprising that here so it's not
castling or anything so this really
surprises me um [ __ ] all nite nite f5 as
this is this good tools night at five it
probably goes Quincy 70 or something
like that
hmm
hard to tell how to tell if I go f5 he
go he goes 'if I've though this this
isn't an idea okay that's that's castle
first and still have nine f5 and long
castles also cover CD 49 probably you
will also cancel long
yeah I don't know I don't want to be in
this in this pin all the time maybe you
can go queen 85 I didn't pay any
attention to this move at all about 96
okay I probably of 96 yeah but ok Quincy
7 is certainly okay for black I go to g3
then or 34 anyway I mean d 4 is the
better square and I can scream survive
now I need to turn it to drop back at it
it's not it's not a bad perennial
problem
and he needs to do something about the
football and I'm not really sure he
wants to play this one year now I can
try to regroup again d force a much
safer square now yeah this is not
helping him I don't think so I'm coming
with you three are anyway hear or see
for opening up the position okay please
let's do see form the ship see 694 is
also very nice from him I hope and if he
takes Knight eggs also looks quite good
I thought but maybe it's a mistaken
mm okay this isn't so great
this is actually intending a 3 and B
form it's not the safety month only yeah
he's just trading pieces
now you can go with you five but he's
got all these pawns on light square so
it's be sure this is a limited piece
I'm not still not sure how to how I
could could improve this right before I
can't go before but it's not really
happy that much yep don't want to be in
the pin
not quite sure what he's doing really
hmm
yeah how to continue look like Queen
efforts i'm probably not really playing
for a win nitey for is maybe pull I
can't go here I can't pay this Queen a
wonders 95 with a fork I didn't see the
fog yeah then this is a good news Chani
took me slack ages two to recognize it
attacking the knight of the bishop and
threatening queen age 8 and 9 a-6 this
looks good check
a fiber singing and he's still in this
rather uncomfortable position here with
the King they I don't see a move really
how would you defend f5 and d7 a.m. and
94 was good but it took me ages to find
it check check check time warning this
wasn't really great right black forfeits
on time war wasn't the best move problem
yeah yeah nite a father what I of course
this was the move I instantly thought of
but I thought o Queen a one is getting
counterplay it's just forgot about the
fact that Quincy 595 is a fork checked
him he probably needs to do something
else check check this is more than
critically infected Dwight Dwight wins
instantly around yet still should be
okay for black no no doubt he allowed
far too much this is probably mistaken
allowing 94 maybe just in the Bishop
Bishop p.m. and stay put like also
cannot really play for for a win here
and I've got it obligated but he
shouldn't lose ready alright thanks for
watching